What's up Psych2Go viewers? It's Donna. You know, the person behind the voice over for the last video on Gawking at the opposite sex.
And, I'm here to introduce a new segment on Psych2Go called:
Psych News Edition.
Where we announce the new discoveries that are happening in the world of psychology.
So, without further ado, let's get on to the first story.
Scientists at the University of Maryland, School of Medicine, lead by Dr. Scott Thomas
claimed to have found a compound that can beat the symptoms of depression within twenty-four hours.
The team focused on a compound called "GABA-NAMS"
And, tested their hypothesis on rats.
Rats are subjected to chronic mild stress that caused the rats to act depressed.
When treated with the compound, scientists were able to reverse the symptoms of depression within twenty-four hours.
That's a huge improvement from current antidepressant medication we have today.
Normally, current medication takes up to two weeks to work.
But, people won't start feeling positive effects until six to eight weeks.
Now, the study hasn't been done on humans yet so, I'm a little bit skeptical of it as of now.
Just by the fact that sometimes depression is caused by external events.
Whether that be bullying, abuse or financial problems.
Before taking medication those external problems need to be addressed first, a pill will not make those problems disappear.
Don't get me wrong, any sort of progress in the realm of science is a great thing.
And only good can come out of this new discovery.
Our second story comes from the University of Pennsylvania
and it's for you, frequent migraine sufferers.
I've got good news and bad news.
The bad news is being prone to migraines is genetic.
If you often get them that's that and you're born with what you have.
The good news is researchers have found a link to migraines and an incomplete circle of Willis.
The circle of Willis is the joining area of several arteries of the brain.
Because of that finding, researchers are now working on other treatments for migraines.
It's coming soon you guys.
And, our final story is about
..screaming.
Screaming is a vital form of human communication.
Without using any words, it can convey messages of excitement or fright.
Furthermore, screams have this effect on the brain that causes it to become alert once it's heard.
That's important of course because it tells us right away that we either need to fight
or run.
That is why Popple and his team at the University of Geneva in Switzerland
asked people to judge screams based on how terrifying they were. In hopes to learn about this mean of communication much more.
Researchers found that roughness in screams range from thirty to one hundred and fifty hertz.
And, the rougher the sound the greater the activation in the Amygdala.
The team suggest that this new information can be used to improve alarms.
Please don't make alarms more annoying.
This one's annoying as it is.
That's the news we have for you this week and we at Psyc2Go would love to hear your opinions on what you learned today.